good morning
and thank you for joining us for this
public webinar event future thailand
innovation and education and workforce
development presented by the stanford
thailand research consortium
my name is matt harvey and i am the
senior director of global initiatives
with the stanford center for
professional development
here at stanford university in
california as we begin
i'd like to remind all of you that live
translation in the thai language is
available for this event
which you can access inside zoom by
selecting the interpretation icon
and selecting thai as your preferred
language you may need to be using the
latest version of zoom to access this
function
however please know that following this
event we will be releasing a video of
this talk which will include thai
subtitling for future reference
i would like to thank all of you for
joining us today and to also extend our
support and good wishes for health to
all of you and your families in thailand
as we continue to navigate the
ever-shifting challenges of confronting
the covet 19 global pandemic
and for today's event i want to express
specific appreciation to the inaugural
community of innovative teaching
scholars
from universities across thailand
joining us today
your work and efforts are deeply
appreciated and will serve as a light
to guide others in creating
transformational experiences
for your peer educators institutions and
for thai students and graduates
additionally i would like to express my
gratitude to our stanford faculty
and the consortium member companies and
the key executives who have been able to
degeneres and offering their time with
us today
across two continents to share their
perspectives on issues of innovation in
education and workforce development
throughout today's event our team will
post notes links and quotes in the
public chat
however if you have a question for our
panelists or have a technical support
question
you may write that in thai or english in
the q a function in zoom
our team members both at stanford and in
thailand will do our best to assist
you for today's event we will feature a
short discussion on the innovative
teaching scholars program with both its
stanford faculty leader
and a participating scholar in the
program followed by our panel discussion
with the stanford faculty and executives
and finally a question and answer
session
where our panelists will be available to
answer questions you submit through the
q
a function in zoom and we encourage you
to do so
to provide all of you with some context
about this work the stanford thailand
research consortium supports research in
social
economic and technological development
areas key to thailand's future success
and align with stanford faculty
expertise the consortium is part of
stanford's office of the vice provost
and dean of research
and is actively managed by our faculty
steering committee and our organization
the stanford center for professional
development
the consortium has over a dozen research
and education projects underway
focusing on a diverse range of topics
including examples such as using
artificial intelligence to support
improved elderly care
reducing deforestation and aiding
smallhold farmers in thailand's
non-province
creating organizational insights and
capacity around leveraging
new models and training methods for
entrepreneurship and innovation skills
studying factors and interventions for
improving the wellness for thai citizens
and our topic for today building
capacity and innovation to improve
education
this work would not be possible without
the generous support of the member
companies of the stanford thailand
research consortium
ais ap and casacorn bank
we are very grateful for their continued
support and engagement for this work
which aims to benefit all of thai
society
also the work of the stanford thailand
research consortium benefits immensely
from our ability to work with our
talented colleagues at scac
their dedicated team continue to support
our research teams to do vital and
important work
that has benefits to thailand
particularly against a backdrop of the
global pandemic
i want to express my deep admiration and
appreciation to the entire seac
organization and team
and i am happy to introduce seac's
managing director
and chief capability officer marina
tarangasi
to say a few words arena
for nearly 30 years my team and i have
worked
to improve educational opportunities to
empower thais
sase is proud to contribute to this
project
with the amazing faculty from stanford
three of thailand's most
forward-thinking companies
and truly dedicated high educators
thailand must do so much more to prepare
its youngest generations
for our competit for our competitive
workforce
for thailand's economy and its people to
regain its competitive age
more youngest generation will need to be
better equipped
doing so involves expanding access to
quality development
services especially in rural areas
ais sigon bank and ap
thailand are selflessly contributing to
the future
of our education system the support from
these three organizations
and the dedication of the thai educators
who have joined our efforts are at the
forefront
of an important transformation they show
what it is possible in empowering
teachers and students
for a better future as a fellow educator
i am very much looking forward to
listening and learning today
so let's get started
thank you mourinho we would now like to
open our official portion of the program
and to introduce you to the innovative
teaching scholars program to set the
stage in context for our panel
discussion
to do so i am proud to introduce our
moderator for today's discussions
leticia britos cavagnaro
adjunct professor in the hasselblattner
institute of design at stanford
along with serving as the faculty lead
of the innovative teaching scholars
program
she is co-director of the university
innovation fellows a stanford e-school
program which empowers students to be
co-designers of their education
in collaboration with faculty and
leaders at their schools
leticia was deputy director of the
national center for engineering pathways
to innovation or epicenter here in the
united states
and has worked with hundreds of
educators and students of all ages
as well as corporate and non-profit
leaders in the us
and internationally leticia
thank you matt and welcome everyone
mad shared those
organizations and individuals who have
made this possible
and queen arena shared the why why is
this initiative important
now i want to build on that and tell you
a little bit about
the the how and what we did
in in this program the innovative
teaching scholars
an initiative of the stanford research
uh stanford thailand research consortium
was a professional development
opportunity
for university educators and it was
quite a unique
opportunity if we are to transform
the higher education system to support
uh
the young people who are going to
build the future we need to empower
and prepare those who are in the front
lines
and those are the teachers in this
program
we selected 50 educators from
nine leading thai universities and they
joined us
back in september of 2020 for a very
intensive program
where they met weekly with a teaching
team
and they explored different approaches
innovative approaches to teaching
supported by research
supported by what we know of how about
how
we learn best and about the skills
and mindsets that we need to give our
students
to build an innovate an
innovation-based economy and society
just an hour ago we're very proud to say
that 47 scholars 47
educators graduated from the program it
was
nine months of hard work of trying new
things
and all in the benefit of the students
the goal has always been what
difference does this make in what the
students can become
not only in terms of you know passing
tests
but in or in in terms of what they can
do
when they are out in the real world when
they're out in the workforce
because we need them to
think as innovators if they're going to
build the future
but instead of me just telling more
about the program
we have invited today one of those
scholars who just graduated from these
nine months
of hard work and study
to tell you a little bit about her
experience
in the program so i'm going to invite
professor nutsuda suman risi uh to join
me here and tell us
a little bit about her experience uh in
the program
i noticed thank you so much for joining
us
um tell us a little bit about you know
you uh your university your position
what you teach
thank you ladies here first for uh
inviting me
and i'm an associate professor
in food science and technology from
kingman goods university of technology
north bangkok
mostly i have most of my students
are undergraduate students and i
i teach biology for the first year
students
food quality and control and food
quality evaluation for the third year
student
and fermented food technology
and food industrial management for
the fourth year students so i have
varieties of
students that are enjoying my class
great and new to that represents just
one of the
many disciplines this program had
uh professors across many different
disciplines
from biology to media studies languages
mathematics uh you name it because we
think that there
are some principles about how we
teach that are valuable across
disciplines and it's about the vision of
what uh we think that uh we can uh
how we can add value to the growth of
our students
um lutsuda tell us uh what value did the
the its program add to your practice as
educator what did you get from it um
actually since i have taught for almost
nine years
already so if my teaching is just like a
routine
just give a lecture uh give give my
students
exercises and and just do the exam
so uh this program
actually got me out of the set my cell
phone
so it's like i i can try new things
something that i would like to try in
the past but i don't have
like times or opportunity to try but
this program
gives me like new ideas
techniques and tools to help my my
students
learning more and um actually i
i love when i can share with my friends
my colleagues my
learning partner and and we can share
experience and we actually i learned
that we face
in the same situation and i get
somebody to walk with me through this
program
yeah and what you mentioned is really
important in something else that i want
to share about the program
that this is not just a workshop just
you know a program
and it's over but it's really uh the
cultivation of a community of practice
of innovative educators
like uh professor nutsuda who are
sharing with one another are inspiring
one another are sharing their struggles
are sharing what works and what doesn't
work
and are inspiring others so we might
start with
a small group if you think about you
know
47 educators you know considering the
number of
university educators across thailand but
we
are confident that they are going to be
inspiration they are going to be
a reference for other uh educators
out there and that that is our the goal
of the program
uh nuts that tell us um you mentioned
your students
um how does do your students benefit
from you being an innovative educator
actually i i also learn from my students
from this program
we have reflection uh
every time after we do experiments and
we try new things with our students so
um i what i can feel is that
my students enjoy my activities enjoy my
class
and uh i think all the activities
i have tried makes them like stimulated
them to
learn more effectively and uh
actually i i like the one that the my
favorite
activities are the um exploration before
explanation
it's like i have my students to explore
what
they will learn before teaching them and
i think they they learn something more
and they have freedom
to to learn yes
thank you so much for sharing and thank
you so much for being here
um we're going to move on now to
introduce the other panelists thank you
so much again
uh it was great that you could share
your perspective
um i'd like to um introduce
the rest of the panelists that will be
sharing their perspectives today
uh we have uh first professor sheri
shepard
she is the richard weiland professor
in the stanford school of engineering
she's also the co-director of the center
for design research and
she is an incredibly innovative
educator and researcher
in education so it has been a great
pleasure
for me to work with shari in this in
this program and uh
i'm hoping that she will share some of
the insights that she has gained
uh i would like to say that you know
this has been
an action research project right like so
not just
understanding um what doesn't work but
trying new things and and figuring out
you know how can we
scale those things how can we uh learn
from what we are trying so it was it has
been a great um
collaboration um and so uh we'll
we'll hear from sherry in that respect
um
we also have uh cantima
lulum
from the chief human resources officer
at ais we also have
uh ron grogg poon paul
the chairman of kassicorn business
technology group
concreting welcome uh we also have
peter karn chandavimol the chief
corporate strategy and creation
officer at ap thailand uh welcome
kunming
thank you for being here thank you all
all for being here
um and apologies if i mispronounce your
names
um i was trying to do my best
with that um we are
um i have a series of questions for you
and i'd like uh for us to really have a
conversation
so if i direct a question to someone and
and and someone else wants to
contribute please do let's let's make
this a a true
um productive conversation but i'd like
to
um start by going to the future inviting
you all to
go to the future with this panel uh
because as we know um things change
at an incredibly fast pace uh these days
it seems um so the future uh will be
here before you know it right like or as
a famous quote says the future is
already here
it's not just it's just not evenly
distributed
so let's think about the future um and
my question to each one of our panelists
from the consortium companies and and of
course
uh sherry as well is what are skills and
knowledge
that you envision will become more
important for employees
in your company's uh 10 years from now
and which might be less important in
that future
concreting can i ask you to get us
started with that
hi
sorry can you eat of course i'll repeat
the question
uh what skills and knowledge do you
envision that will become
important for employees at your company
10 years from now
so let's go to it i think like um
basically the
my quality and the human machine
interaction i think is very important
because in the next 10 years i think we
are all aware that ai will be
the most important like you know
technology of our times
and we need to learn like them to work
with ai i think and because like i'm in
my company we
we apply in every single aspect of our
operation you know like i'm from into in
automation even a software development
because like
you know like even we are trying to work
with tm actually with stanford as well
like i'm on developing um
and um and ai that basically can create
a program itself you know
so i think like we need to learn how to
work with machine you know like that's
number one you know like you are either
like don't want to create the machine
train the machine or work with the
machine or you will be
basically commanded by the machines
which definitely you know do not want to
do that
and in order to do that i think like um
you basically need to develop like um
you know like technology like um
quotient i think like um you know
technology coaching is very important
you know
basically like to understand technology
how to apply technology because like
every single company and every single
aspect of our life would be impacted by
technology
and then like i think like we shouldn't
lose the um touch of
the strength of human being you know
basically like um like
you know like i'm the things that like
empathy agility you know like
an ability to learn and learn and learn
i think and um and i think the um lesson
let's say
especially during this time i think like
um in the next 10 years i think we
i call it like on the edge of like
continuous disruption you know like
every single like um you know like
exponential technology will converge and
then
like create exponential changes you know
like every single year so i think like
um we we need to learn how to adapt
be agile really salient you know like
i'm learning to work with the machine
and um definitely i think like um
like um ability to continuously like
renew ourselves i think like
for me that's more important than the
subject matter
like you know knowledge because like in
community we have like
a lot of programs to rescue employees so
i think like um you know
like when they come they're smart you
know like they work hard and they have
the good attitude you know like um they
can definitely like for example
i think like um like one of the best
data scientists he basically like
a petroleum engineering you know student
he like we like um and they're like i'm
the
the best like um business analyst you
know like um for our call banking
basically like um they don't they have
like business education they don't have
like any like technology background at
all when they like
you know with the right attitude and
ability to learn and um they
they don't they don't like them you know
like um and then also like ready to
challenge the status
quo i think it's kind of like a more
like a skill and competency than like
subject matter knowledge you know
[Music]
great like you uh covered a lot there i
just want to kind of like
um summarize some of the things you
mentioned um
empathy the ability to learn and relearn
the ability to adapt
uh the ability and mindset to challenge
the status quo
um i think that that's that's a
wonderful uh
uh concatema uh what is your perspective
in this regard what
what are the the skills knowledge
mindsets that will be important
ten years from now in your company and
your field
i would say good thing to all you know
all the
important points but anyway it's precise
uh
the digital you know technology all
those type of thing i think that's the
communication is will play an
important role but in a different way
in the past you know we have everyone
sit in the office working together
those type of things but you know things
with dependent mix make things
change you see that the communication
will play an important role especially
when people
change their working style and precise
that is the active learning
i think that's very important because
the responsibility
of the career growth and skill set
adaptability is also depends on i would
say
in the past it's more on organization
side that you know provide to
the staff but now it's no longer i think
that's it's 50 50
responsibilities because the company
or the organization can provide access
in general
to to all those knowledge but the other
uh
the active learning skill is something
that the
employee need to bear in mind that you
know
they have to keep themselves uh adapt
and every time
you see that things change now today
when things change it's changed faster
and more you know i i would say we're
talking about it
especially in thailand we're talking
about digital transformation which is i
would say that
is huge bigger than change management
you know you change your dna you change
the way
and precise that that i think that we
need to focus
on the culture change so people have to
have the abilities
you know to adapt to change because
whatever the company
believe whatever the the education
system believes is no longer be the same
anymore it will change faster
so ability that they can adapt to change
is very important
last but not least is the leadership i
think leadership need to change
big change especially in asian context
because
whatever we believe that you know uh
respectful are those we need to give the
rooms
we need to give the room and the stage
you know the new generation they need
the spotlight on themselves
because you know they have all those
skill sets so
the leader need to adapt ourselves a lot
in terms of
changing the way we think changing the
way we leading the team
so so those is the thing that i need to
to
to address last point is what
will we we see that less important i
think that uh
i would say that uh it's not be able
i i could not say it's less important
but
it will change faster all the knowledge
or the technology will move very fast so
so that that's how i see thank you thank
you for sharing that
um and you mentioned uh the importance
of culture
change and and the role of leadership um
and and i will remind everyone that uh
we
have been my colleague minou um has
added um
has been adding some uh highlights some
quotes
uh from uh the responses that you just
heard
to provoke questions
we really want questions from all of you
who are who are listening
to this panel and you can add your
questions at any time
in the q a box uh we will address those
questions at the end but please
add them and we're adding these these
summaries these quotes uh
from the panelists um to
uh get you uh curious and and get you
um asking questions so please do um
so uh konming uh what is uh your
perspective
in this regard what is the future um
in your company uh to be the third one
to to
answer this question i think i need to
it's kind of uh pretty much similar to
what could um
give uh and good mentions
but i would like to summarize into two
big things that
the future um the future skill that we
need is the first one is
cognitive flexibility at the speeds of
the business world
has been isolated driven by the
technologies and new inventions
everyone has to really family and with
the change
this means that they they have to
embrace changes
improve ability to learn and
understanding the unknown or
evolving market that they are facing be
able to adapt your
decisions and actions to the complex
problems
quickly with this ability they can enjoy
them have the confidence to have a fresh
and innovative ideas
and i think some of the example very
basic example of the cognitive
flexibilities in the workplace is that
the people like um like the people who
are comfortable
with the job locations to the new area
they open
to to learn and they open to to move
to the uncomfort zone
and this is the first one that i think
um is quite critical when
we are looking to ski in the future and
the second one
everybody talk about this is a social
skills
this includes emotional intelligence
skill to
collaborate with others and
communication or negotiation
this would make people different from
and better than robots in the future as
mentioned
in the next 10 years we will see a lot
of job automations and robots replacing
our current jobs privately recognizing
the colleague facial or verbal
explanations
emphasizing the root causes or adjust
behavior accordingly
would be very complex alcoholism for the
robot
that means we can manage expectation
from from there it's from our brain
expressions
ability to effectively correlate with
uh or work with the multi-discipline
is also crucial as the future problems
will be more complex and need a
different knowledges
or skills to solve them and
for the point of the less important
skill i think
other skills for the existing
technologies
in in my area like in the architectural
designs
area um two-dimensional order that's you
would be obsolete in the near future
with the replacing like three
dimensional building skills
these are my comments yeah thank you so
much for
for adding so much nuance uh to um
something that that is so fascinating
right that if we look at the
from the perspective uh of the workforce
um and and you mentioned the importance
of social emotional skills
um and let's look at now uh from the
perspective of
um the university so so sherry um
as a university educator who has also
worked
in industry for many years what what are
some gaps that you see between the
what the students get as learning
experiences and the
the skills uh they or the challenges
they face when they enter the workforce
and you're muted sharing
um i would say one related to
instance who scopes the work you know
when you take a university class
you're given a syllabus and a set of
assignments with due dates
and and you move methodically through a
a
course and you're done with the course
at the end of a semester
your work doesn't come in semester
chunks
and you know your assignments may
include the emergency thing that needs
to get done tomorrow
and a longer range project and so one of
the things i think students are not well
equipped to do is is
time management in terms of keeping all
those balls going
and along with all the communications
you need to be doing with various team
members
i would say another challenge is
academic
teams even on design projects are made
up so students
can sit around the table and work
together on designing something
real design often doesn't happen that
way especially with distributed teams
and
and you may join a team for a few weeks
you may join another team for months and
so how do you manage those relationships
and really get to know what the project
is what you can contribute
um get to know the other people on it
and then realize
you'll move on to another team i would
say another thing
is students learning what is it to lead
um and
yeah it may be that you're the person
with a big title
but in a team project how do you take a
part of it and actually take ownership
while still collaborating with others
and so i would say that's another area
that many academics struggle with in
terms
of of how to give students those kind of
experiences
but i would say in general all of those
kind of skills that we'd like to see
students to be better at
really shift us away from the old
paradigm of a teacher-centered classroom
you know where you have an expert who's
giving his or her lecture
and students are copying dutifully down
the notes
and maybe processing them later they
really call for i would say a messier
classroom
in terms of the kind of prompt that's
given
and i really appreciated the idea of
experiencing before
explaining um having students work
together
so it requires all of us to think in new
ways on
what is a university classroom yeah
that's that's beautiful and if
we remember what uh professor nutsuda
mentioned when i asked her about you
know her experience with the program she
said i'm a learner i learn from my
students as well
and i think that developing that
attitude
having educators that are see themselves
as learners
right is what we need to um you know
inspire the students
and and send them the message that you
know you're not going to learn all that
there is to learn
and then graduate and be ready right
like learning is something that you will
continue
and as concreting mentioned earlier as
well you know it's about also
on learning and relearning right like so
it's something that
a mindset that they really need to
acquire um
and and that was uh one of the goals of
the program
um if um i have a question about like so
uh sherry mentioned
um some of the the these skills of like
time management communication with team
members collaboration in teams
um that you know maybe the universities
are not doing such a great job of
preparing the students with um
any of you wants to uh share what how
much does your company or
all of you how much do your companies um
need to invest uh to in
um to get a new employee employee just
fresh out of the university up to speed
and to be
effective and efficient in as part of
your organization
konkanima do you want to get us started
for sure i i think that from the
experience not not only in ais
but i think that uh in our education
system
when i when i talk about education
system you see that uh
especially in in asia uh
our culture also effect on the way we
educate our people you know
the the school students mean the student
who
you know follow what the teacher you
know recommend and
be nice all the time those will be
identified as the
good student but the student who
challenged the teacher what oh you know
they will come ask you know the naughty
boy not to care
so i think that uh for for the education
in thailand i think that
is need to be changed to fit with the
private sector need when we look at this
we see that
uh the new fresh the graduate
the most challenge is they lack of the
experience like uh
you guys just mentioned the lack of
experience in the
world of work the lack of working
experience they're working in some
project
with the student and the teacher but in
terms of doing the training
with the company i think that most of
the job that been assigned to all these
students is
firing you know the document doing the
some company also doing the
they asked the student to do the copies
those type of things so so it's not the
real experience
now today i think that things change
even in the private sector you know all
success
one won't be the good guarantee for the
future success
so we need to disrupt ourselves
especially in the education system
i i start seeing the collaboration
between the private sector
and the education institute you know the
school
and the private sector need to work
together
in terms of design the curriculum those
type of things the private sector
could step in and help more to get the
student ready
to work in the real world before they
graduate
i i used to sit in in one
meeting with the older professor i know
that in this room there's number of
professors listen to this
mainly we want to make change on our
student
but we never look at ourselves what need
to be
changed on ourselves so i think that's
very important
before we tell the next generation what
they have to do
we come back and revisit that what we
need to adapt ourselves so those is will
help you know to get the education
system
be stronger be ready and then you know
cope with the fast pace that things
change
so so that's that's how i see
thank you so much um
to me i think there are two points on
this one
is the first thing is about how to
measure
the quality of the student besides that
taking the test
um that would be only one dimensional um
qualifications is about the knowledge uh
that's the thing that i think is quite
important from my experience a good
grade person
really confirm um that they are gonna be
the good employee
or the uh the um the best of before
using the
internet company that's the first point
and the second point would be
the um the way they they work in the
project-based learning
uh most of the time of the student
always work with the similar
similar kind of knowledge plan in the
project
meaning that they are working with the
friend in the same faculties or
something like that
but in the real world we have to work
with the different people
different knowledge different experience
for example like
in in my company in ap architect
architect have to work with the
engineers and also have to work with my
team across this discipline that would
make them um be more knowledgeable
in their area and they have to share
they have to open up and collaborate
with the different engines
that would help people more
more become more effective in terms of
work with the different
people
i i i for me like um i think like um i
totally agree with both and i think like
um
the um like um the problem that i have
is that like um i have to re-skill the
students basically to what board them
for like six months
you know like i'm six months and then
like i'm you know like for them to be
ready for the new grad
to be ready for the job and um and also
like when they look at the
grade the gta the way they re-evaluate
or test the student
it doesn't have much correlation with
the real performance of the students you
know
because like um it takes a lot more you
know like um more than the
subject matter like um like a knowledge
you know like um then like um
to be like a really effective like um
key member of the company you know like
cultural faith ability to learn ability
to communicate
leadership initiative that kind of stuff
and also the other thing that we
we find is that like you know like like
like for subject matter expert you know
like even like a student that get like a
gpa of like four you know like in
programming that kind of stuff
and then like some of them fail the
taste of like um codility that kind of
thing you know
because like i'm you know like the
professional test is like um
it's not the same as the test that they
took in the university so like that's
number one
and um and number two so that's why like
i'm for kbdt ourselves we um
we engage with right now like 10
university you know like we have a
program called kvdg tech campus
that that we basically reach out to 10
university
and we work with them the um like um to
develop a telecom feedback on curriculum
and also like um
send our um send our team members you
know like um to work closely with the
professors and also the students
on doing like both core research and
also like you know like i'm working on a
project together
since like um the third year so that
like students know like whether they
they are better you know like and it's
also kind of like career guidance as
well like you know like you work on the
project like for some students you know
they didn't know that like i'm probably
like i want to be data engineer data
scientist you know like
i want to be like i don't want to be
like a software programmer but probably
like you know like i want to be like a
security
cyber security guy or like that kind of
stuff like you know so that's the um
what we are trying to do so basically
like i'm
working closely like i'm with the
university
to to um to to to develop a curriculum
and also like i'm also the taste and
also teaching and also
involve the students like um early on
and also the professor early on
so that's like you know like we don't
have to like um like um to rescue like
you know
and because for us like it's a big
problem you know imagine like
we this year we will get like a 300
actually 400 new employees and 400 new
employees that are like them you know
like um they need to ram up their skill
for six months you know
so that's like we like last year we took
the initiative like you know
like um to um because it's like i'm the
first year of co with last year right so
we revamped the whole orientation and
kind of stuff
we like um develop like um you know like
the whole employee experiences and also
like um the online learning that kind of
thing
so then like um employee can can get up
to speed like much faster
to improve the productivity so that's
what we i'm trying to do
so um from kbdg point of view yeah
thank you so much for sharing that and i
i'd like to um
come back in a second to you know
concreting you mentioned you know
getting involved with the universities
and the professors early on and i want
to come back to that but uh
i want to first explore something uh
i believe it was coming who mentioned
the measuring the quality of the
students an assessment and i wanted to
share with everyone that
as part of the the its program uh the
scholars
learn a series of what we call
pedagogical levels
or you know areas where they can really
think about
how they design the learning experience
of their students
uh and there's two uh the area of
assessment that is incredibly important
right
and that it and really going beyond
just the test right like the traditional
test that oftentimes are not
part of what the the professors can't uh
decide right like it's it comes from you
know the
the standards it might come from the the
government
and the students have to take those
tests but there are many other ways of
assessment
in which the educators can give students
uh feedback and information about how
they're learning and how can they
you know uh grow um in in a given
discipline
or or in their capacity to learn and
that is something that is incredibly
important that educators
design and think about and and i'd like
to ask uh
sherry because i know for instance
sherry that uh
a member of your teaching of your
research team of the research team
of this project dr helen chen
works does a lot of work with portfolios
and which can be a form of assessment
can you uh
tell us a little bit more about that and
any other forms
of assessment of measuring um the
the quality and the work of the students
that you're seeing us as
promising and innovative so in terms of
of
both students being able to then
themselves think about
you know what are my assets and where
are my gaps and where do i need to be
working on
my my abilities um
seeing that partially as as a major
responsibility of students
to really say if if these are the kind
of skills that are needed
in the organ types of organization where
i need to be working
how do i prepare myself and some of that
may come through the courses a lot of it
will
you know the projects you work on how do
you communicate those and reflect on
them yourself
about you know if it was a team project
what work did what worked well what
didn't
work well you know how much you need to
work on your your
presentation skills or your
communication skills based on that
experience and reflecting on it and then
how do you
tell that story to others you know
beyond your faculty to employers
so that they can start to see in fact
the range of abilities
that you have demonstrated both inside
of the classroom
and outside of the classroom when helen
works on this
with students it's very personal in the
sense that she's really having them dig
deep
and look more broadly of what their
engagements have been you know as they
grow up
and as they go through the university
and that may be
extracurricular activities um in the
united
states students very much value doing
internships in the summer as a way that
they can try a field on
you know and and increasingly employers
like
ford are really seeing that as a way and
place to
sell prospective employees on the uh
on the company as well as watch and
observe what their abilities are so
internships and students coming back to
the classroom
after that summer experience and say how
is what i'm learning related to
what i'm going to be expected to do in
an organization
but some of it can also come through
extracurricular activities of leading a
club or
starting a club um so you know helen's
work is really around a big reflection
on the student
for them to take ownership of skill
learning and then how do you communicate
that out and so it's one example of
moving beyond kind of the standard
resume
that students have gotten very used to
typing up with a list of things
that that hopefully open a door to an
employer but i suspect even
with all of you in hr you actually want
to know more about what
is this student capable of in terms of
of thinking
creatively taking risks and getting work
done
excellent thank you so much and um
sherry for for sharing that
um and i'm going to break the rules here
and hopefully no one gets
mad at me but i am seeing a question
from the audience
um that i think is incredibly relevant
to this
that we're talking about about you know
measuring and
the students measuring the the
performance of the students
so um i'd like to hear uh from the
the company's uh representatives how are
you
uh thinking what are the hiring
parameters of the future
right if grades are a poor um
indicator for future performance what
might be
you using or what are you using right
now
and concreting i know that you have to
um
move on at three minutes so
go ahead so um i think like um for me
like i'm basically we utilize like um
the um some of the
for example because my company is a tech
company you know like i'm so we use like
codility to test the um the
coding skill you know like that kind of
thing we do like um programming like i'm
you know like um like um
kind of like case like um interview that
kind of stuff and also to see
how they approach the problem and how to
break down the problem you know
see and also like when they engage with
us in the problem
solving situation how do we feel working
with this person
you know so that's how we see it you
know a case interview that kind of thing
and also
like the other thing that will be more
in the future you know it's kind of like
you see the rise of it take that
involved in the um the so-called like um
you know
like um secure assessment that kind of
stuff and also the attitude like
assessment
and i think like in the future you know
like um there will be more and more like
i'm social validation
or like a peer validation you know and
especially because the skill will be
more like a
nano skill no qualification for example
like um you
submit a project you know like i'm on 2d
i'm like you know
onto the system and then like the more
people use your code you know like a
snippet of the program then like you
know like um you get like a
higher score of that you know as well
like it smells like citation
in the research community as well there
will be a social validation
like a peer mechanism and also expert
like um skills similar to like linkedin
what linkedin is trying to do
so there will be a lot of stuff that we
um that we need to um to assess like all
together
i'll see like it will be more
comprehensive more technology based
more adaptive and also like a more
social based you know like um like a
more like a voting mechanism as well i
think like
but that will be the challenge for the
hr to deal with
so and um and i have to leave right now
and thank you very much for this
very exciting opportunity and panels
we really appreciate it thank you so
much for joining us and let's hear
uh from funkantima and kun ming
about this
i i would say that in terms of the
the the test or those type of things i
think that in thailand we always have a
job
that if you see the student who have a
high grade you know
straight a or stress you know
although students there's potentially
that they're gonna fail
in the workplace because mainly is they
focus on those theoretical
instead of the real experience so
psychometric is becoming another
important test that whether we
see that those those students have the
have the growth mindset or the
adaptability to change so those type of
things that in the private sector that's
how we
see we we might say that uh
the the overall in the in
in the organization always look at the
the rating of the student
but on the other way around we will see
that there's
a number of the students who experience
in terms of doing those
activities with the university or even
you know
launched some project before those will
be the other
the other source that when we check that
whether they are fit with our our need
or not so so those is the
how we evaluate when when we so
what i what i reflect is at the
university as well
before the student graduate i think that
we need to change the
belief that you know doing on only the
on the only the skill in the in the
functional skill that soft skill size
that the university
need to make sure that you also develop
the student
and also get them ready for for the real
world yep
thank you okay um if you ask this
question we have to come from
from the corporate point of view when
they get into
the real world most of the time they
work in the project test
or even that in the future most of the
time
the job would be the project test and
how to measures on the project is about
the output of the project
and we want to see when we then when we
when we see the output we will try to
understand how they apply
or the theory or knowledge in order to
deliver the output
and this would be very helpful if other
students can be practiced
and then be measured when they are in
the universities
and they when they get instead of taking
the multiple choices or even uh
the explanations of the theory
uh we want to see um how they can apply
all the theory that they learned and
deliver
the different outputs from the same
questions that you asked that would be
very helpful
thank you thank you so much and and i
want to go back to something that
we mentioned earlier around the
collaboration between
companies and universities
and i want to also make a comment that
the companies that are represented here
not only
were very generous in supporting uh this
project
of the stanford thailand research
consortium financially
but are also doing so intellectually and
i think that this is
really uh an important thing right that
we are
having this conversation is an important
thing
right that we have a group of
corporate leaders business leaders
and university educators having a
conversation
asking questions and asking of one
another what can we do
together better for the you know
to uh improve the future of of
of thailand so um i'd like to ask
both of you ming and kun kantina
to share some examples of how your
companies have
explored working with universities in
the past and maybe some ideas for the
types of collaborations that you would
like to see
in the future or engage with in the
future
okay um since um 2016 ap thailand
has transformed the practical trainings
of the
third and fourth year state university
student into
the kind of valuable time for them to
really learn and practice knowledge
that we teach and also the knowledge
from the universities
we call it ap open house if you in open
house is a one month intensive program
that um enhance the um
student to practice it will be focused
on the
civil engineering at the beginning and
then we expand to architect and market
teams so they
they not only to have the um a chance
to really practice the um
in the real business network they also
develop the future skills through the
site thinking process
and the project management and we also
see that
the collaboration with university is a
critical driver for the
internal innovations um
stanford thailand research consulting is
one of the examples that we incorporate
with the research team from
stanford university and thai university
um to work
with our ap international uh
team has a chance to really explore new
ideas processes and knowledge
coming from the university why um
university technologies
are working on their research and
moreover in the future we want to
cooperate with the
different faculties different
universities to create cross battery
collaborations such as creating the
project
with the serial engineer student
to work with the architectural student
or
product design student to work with
marketing and software engineering
students
in order to really enhance their future
skills
of the collaborations communication and
social skills
this is my comment
on ais i think that are pretty similar
to
ap but on the the the
we we separate into section the first
one is we work with the teacher
uh we have the program called educate
educator thailand which is
uh we we just about start this year
having about over 100 teachers
that coming in and change them give them
the skill
that need to be changed to match with
the
private sector requirement that they
have to skip for example like you see
that
when the pandemic happens things that we
face the big challenge is the ability of
the educator in terms of using
and maximize the technology into their
teaching progress so those is one thing
that we do
the second one is we work with the
teacher it's on the tutor thailand
besides the teacher we see that all the
tutors in thailand play an important
role
in terms of you know skill up the
student to have the abilities
uh to to achieve them that that goal
on the student side we have the training
which is almost like the other
organization
but we also running the project we call
academy for times
we using our experience that when we
transform our organization from telecom
company
to be the digital service provider we
found that there are many knowledge
that need to be
educated to advertise people include
including the students so this is the
academy for thai projects that we work
with our partner as well
uh guessing also support at ap
also support ad in terms of the program
we call academy for thai
and then the the newest project that we
run is we call
thailand which is bring all the students
who have those
innovation but they lack of the support
from the big
organization to come and work together
in terms of
you know bring that innovation idea
become real so those is the project that
in terms of the private sector roles
that we play
thank you uh before we move to
questions um from um the audience and
thank you so much for all of you who
have contributed please continue to do
so
and we'll hope to get to as many
questions as we can
i'd like to ask um sherry i mentioned at
the beginning that
the its program is not just a one-off
workshop but it's really a community of
practice
we're nurturing a community of practice
can you tell us how
can developing a community of practice
can be beneficial to educators
uh in in and and more importantly to
their students
uh and what are some of the signs uh or
indications that a community of
practices
is thriving and and can you know grow
and scale
um and and have a more um
permanent effect in the education system
thanks latisha you know i think one of
the notions here
is to move from this idea that an
educator
is a solo agent in the classroom you
know
with his or her students and they closed
the door and and
that's all that happens between that
community and really
shifted to the idea that educators are
innovators which means they're going to
have new ideas they need a community to
bounce those ideas off of and and add to
it
and and then they run an experiment
called a class session or a course
and things go well and they don't they
instrument it
and they really are part of a larger
team that can give
feedback and so that's you know moving
towards a community a practice where
you really do have collaborators who are
giving you
input a community of practice also means
that new people can come in
that don't have all of those cool
teaching levers
and they can start learning from people
who've been doing these innovations
longer so
it's also not a closed wall kind of
community it really has some
permeability
of recognizing people changing roles and
welcoming new people to the team
so i have to say for educators it's a
real paradigm shift
from the notion that you know you've got
your course and you deliver it
and there may be a review at the end but
really saying it's an experiment and
every time you teach it you
will have reflected on what well what
didn't go well
what new technologies are there and so
you're in fact
always changing and you could say it
actually makes teaching
more work because you know it's not a
standard course that you pull the folder
out
and you give that same lecture that
you've given you know the last five or
ten years
you're continuing to adopt it but i have
to say it sure makes
teaching and learning a heck of a lot
more fun
yeah definitely and and i think it
models also for the students that if you
are experimenting if you are trying new
things
that's what we want them to be able to
do as innovators in the future right and
when they are
finding themselves in a new context
where they have to learn new skills
um that you know not everything is you
know
uh clean clear-cut and you know
easy but you know they have to try
different things and experiment so i
think it's a great way to
to model that from their educators um
thank you sherry i'm going to move to
the questions from the audience and
thank you everyone who has contributed
questions actually a question from one
of our scholars
ray wong he says i agree culture change
is important
but at least from what i've seen there
still can be a quite a bit of resistance
to new ideas
changes here in thailand i wonder if the
panelists can give further thoughts
about this issue and how to address it
i take it so i i think that uh
we experienced
in ais i think that the
the first time that we want to change
the way we
develop our stuff we we used to have the
training department for a long time
so we decided to you know disrupt the
training department
we would change the way we educate our
staff
at the beginning is so hard it's so
tough because
people could not understand why we need
to disrupt
because people still stick with the old
success that
we tend to believe that the old success
and the old solution
will bring us to the future success but
in reality
the contexts are different so we disrupt
our training department by replace with
the ais
academy which is working with the
internal and external together
because why we need the external because
external also educate us
in terms of the ability to adapt to
change in the real world
so what we at the beginning is so hard
and then we end up with we just launched
the new company culture
last year and we believe that when we
put the company cultures there
people tend to stick with all those even
the context change
so whatever the culture that we believe
is need to be
changed along the way as well so
the way that we manage is the
communication
plan very important role we have the
podcast
every week to the staff instead of you
know sometimes when you
educate through the all those hierarchy
you're not going to be success because
story keep change
depends on each leader you know going to
interpret in that world
so the communication plan very important
role in terms of you know when you want
to change the culture or those
and the other very important thing is
the company always
enjoy that you see a very small number
of turnover rate
we see that as the success before but we
lost the opportunity to have the
diversity in the
organization as well so mix and match is
something that we need to change
and the most population that we need to
change the way we see things first in
ais is we change
the way we shift the paradigm of the
leaders
because the leader always could become a
big
barrier for all those organization
chains
so so those those our experience
um quite similar thought to asd i think
in order to forfeit change you have to
come from the top
the top have to buy in with the change
first and
um and then when we after we have the uh
the agreement with all the top
management
management that we want to change um
then our hr can work more easier
to really drive change and then when we
look at the resistance we can see that
it is in ap for example is kind of the
generation
as well um lucky us up that we have
pretty much deadline things that is the
majority of our employees
they are willing to adapt to change so
there is another small group within
resistance
that we are working on
and with all those cultures from the top
and from the younger generation that
they are
they want to work with change they want
to stay their open teachers
it's kind of easier for for us
um hr to really work with a small group
of people
to reduce their resistance
thank you sharon what is here can i just
just add one more point of course of
course
uh the other things that we need to
change the way we see in the
organization is the satisfaction
the company always the organization
always enjoy the high score of
satisfaction score when we doing the
survey
but satisfaction is one of the reasons
of creating
the comfort zone so those is something
that we need to balance well enough
between satisfaction or engagement
you might see that many organizations
who have a very high satisfaction
you see that the potential and ability
to adapt to change is
become lower because people stick in
their comfort zone
and when you measure the commitment of
the staff who have the high satisfaction
you might not see the same you know
level of satisfaction and commitment so
those is the thing that i wanna you know
yeah that that's interesting yeah i i
hadn't thought about that but yeah
you might have some employees that are
actually maybe
itching for change right like and
and how do you yeah how do you address
that and balance that
sherry you had uh i think you were into
it
yeah i think another organizational
structure that needs to be
part of this cultural set of questions
are the academies
you know and to what extent are are they
uh prepared to actually celebrate these
our 47 scholars in terms of both
inspiring them to continue in their own
classrooms but also to take various
leadership
roles in their universities and how does
that get rewarded
and recognize that you know risk
can be a good thing in terms of
experimenting
um you know looking at different ways of
then judging
universities and and you know one might
be a measure of student engagement
and what would that look at like as a
measure
in a university as opposed to
research dollars or what other metrics
are used to maybe
uh rank universities so i think it's an
organization let's not forget
may need to have some cultural shifts as
well
yeah that that's a great point right
like we talked about the
changing or thinking about innovative
ways to assess
students we really need to also innovate
in how we assess
teachers right like how what we um
you know incentivize right like any um
and and we we will um one thing that
we're
uh really happy to to say is that this
project will continue
for another year again thank you um to
the the generous contribution
of the the companies um that are
represented here
that that are supporting the the
consortium um
in in in this new year we're really
looking to
thinking about how the the the scholars
who
participated in this inaugural cohort
become
leaders uh in these for the new cohort
right like and that
will require that their universities
support them
right and that they see the work that
they're doing
uh in inspiring other colleagues in
you know participating in this community
of practice as something that is as
valuable
as the research as valuable as their
teaching right
um so um that's something that uh that
that we will be
testing and and encouraging um
and it will be interesting to see how
even the companies can contribute in
that
regarding sending that message right
like that we need uh
these innovative educators to prepare
the students that will
you know be the future of our of of your
industries and and
and the society right um so that's
that's a great point of like thinking
about how we incentivize the
the teachers as well um uh one question
um that uh came from the audience i'm
going to
um simplify it a little bit but the
question had to do
um with what people often
call soft skills right and we know that
companies want employees that possess
both
the domain specific technical skills uh
but also soft skills
right which do you find is harder to
recruit for
i think it's very hard you know
interviewing is take
an hour so it's not enough to prove that
whatever we see
we always lost the opportunity by
picking up the success candidate from
the great presentation
so some of the candidates who have a
a good presentation skill will be doing
good in terms of you know
but the growth mindset is something that
i think that we need to really focus on
those because
uh there's a number of cyclomatic tests
that that can help you know as the
guideline
before we have the interview session
to re to reconfirm in terms of you know
the potential of the score that we see
the soft skill is something that is
takes some time
uh for the people who picking up and
change the way they're getting used to
but i think that the the for the
leadership when we recruit the leaders
we looking for the constructive
feedback skill because that seems to be
a very
big challenge and for the student we
looking for people who all have the open
mind
to get the feedback because for the
leader
level if they have the constructive
feedback skill
that will help the organization in terms
of
scale up the the staff but
for the staff taking is too personal
something is become a
barrier to to develop themselves because
when we hear the feedback we see that
those
managers want to attack us so so those
is the things that we think that is the
good start of the other soft skill
yeah yeah and and just to clarify
concatenate when you say
constructive feedback skill you mean
both giving feedback
and receiving and acting on the feedback
yeah because in asia and in asia context
you know uh for the seniority you know
saying things for the junior people tend
to
you know need to knock their head and
you know accept that and not
not really challenge them back but on
the other way around
for the the boss the leader or the
managers have a very hard time in terms
of you know
giving the constructive feedback for for
the staff in terms of development them
because they see that this is something
that uh
gonna hurt their feeling it's gonna make
them upset
so we lack of this in in asian
contact that's how i see so i i think
that that will help
as a good start in terms of develop the
other soft skill
thank you um
to qualify during the recruiting process
um especially during their 30 to 15
minute interview
period the high skill
kind of different but or what we all
always
do it to test the first thing is about
soft skills
we will test them through the interview
um with the
um the way they can manage complete
whether they can really have the um the
abilities to work with unexpected
patients um because most of the time
they will
prepare for some certain questions that
they've been told
but um that's that we want them to
expect the unexpected that's what we
want
um we really i um personally used to
test all those
candidates who come to my interview and
we see that um
most of the time people will lose
control of their emotion
when they get pushed and those kind of
thing that we
need to test them during the injury
that's the only thing that you can do
during the um recruiting process
and the reason that we are focusing on
the
um soft skill or emotional
um control because we think that the
hospital can be trained by the company
but the attitude and the emotional
control is very difficult to
exchange people if they are not trained
for them
when they are young um great thank you
so much uh
sherry um when we talk about soft skills
and and hard skills you know you are
an engineering professor you um
teach you know hardcore engineering
courses right i feel that um
some pro some uh professors uh who teach
courses like yours might think like well
you know all of those soft skills that's
not my job
right like i'm teaching them all of
these you know solve these equations
build these structures
but i know you have a different
perspective and you have great
you know uh examples or at least you
know some that i know of and probably
you have more
of you know integrating uh both you know
what
people call soft skills and and hard
skills
into your teaching can you share some
examples
thanks leticia well i would first say
that we always
we don't always do a great job of
teaching
the hard skills either because i think
sometimes
that analytic stuff can be so
sanitized you know that that it's you're
given a
perfect situation and you apply the
equations
and even in applying those equations in
real world problems there's messiness
you know if if you're designing a
building um you know you're actually
thinking about what the structure is the
size of the beams there's lots of
variables
as you're really moving towards applying
the equations so first of all
i think it's important to show that
ambiguity
and the assumptions that you need to
make and then
there's those added layers of the
ambiguity of working with others that
are contributing to the ideas of what
you're designing and so
that naturally actually makes it more
realistic to add
in that you and a partner are needing to
actually argue about what the form of
the structure is going to be
and make decisions on the materials and
your priorities and what your design
requirements are and and that really
draws
in those things about being able to
listen to be able to explain
to be able to diagram to be able to
present to negotiate you know
what we would call soft skills and so i
actually think that
that layering those in and having
students work
problems or engage in projects that are
more authentic
is a natural way to pull it in and i
have to say
it makes it so much more exciting for
students i mean sometimes they get a
little frustrated and say just give me
the clean problem sets
but when they can see that they can
start to put a little of their
personality into the work
in terms of designing something that's
important to them
it really makes them sparkle in a
classroom so
you know i don't think it's this extra
layered thing i mean i think it really
makes
that hard stuff come alive
yeah thank you thank you for sharing
that um
so earlier we were talking about the
importance of having
young people who adapt to change we're
comfortable
learning and relearning and we have had
you know
uh a pandemic that has forced us all to
think about
different ways of working and and
learning um i i'd love to hear from the
companies
um how you know how have you
what adjustments have you made and how
have you helped
um employees at your companies um you
know
adapt and work differently during the
pandemic
and and has this changed your views of
uh
of how people can work um you know
in effectively um
given this situation
the thing to ask is that first of all
they have to adapt to take new
technologies they have to use so
commonly hidden and they have to really
learn how to
um the custom is not stable and they
have to learn how to really work on that
um uh the second thing
is that they um since they are working
from home
they have to have the abilities to
coordinate with force everybody
they have we have to try to facilitate
them to really um
give other tools things together
to make them work more effectively um
the third type
third thing is that um especially for
our
business is the um residential
property development it is very
difficult for our customers to visit the
site
visit the project due to the pandemics
so we have to develop all the new
technologies for themselves
before to really um work with our
customers remotely
so basically um with the pandemic
all the technologies that we have
currently
can be applied and people have to really
adapt to those technologies
for ais i think that uh for in terms of
organization all those tools and
accessibility is something that the
organization
is very focused on the the
digital experience is become a very
important role
in the pandemic situation i think that
we start seeing
all those uh i would say the
the elderly generation they start using
some technology
not only our stuff like the e-banking or
those type of thing you know people
tend to adjust very well the benefit of
the
pandemic is you see that people adapt
themselves faster
they equip themselves faster than is
used to
so i i think that in terms of
organization the experience on those
digital
and access to those two is very
important
whether we like it or not we're not
gonna change back to what we're
getting used to i think that working
from home now
is only the the the start
but you see that the world's gonna be
smaller people gonna work from anywhere
in the world
and things that that's the beauty of the
benefit of the technology
so i think that the company need to
support
in terms of equip our staff ability
to use and maximize the benefit of
technology so those is the thing that we
focus
uh on the staff also another fifty
percent i
i i have a strong belief in fifty fifty
percent
responsibility roles that the staff also
need to
equip themselves don't afraid that
they're gonna lose that job because of
the pandemic
i think that people are gonna lose that
opportunity for the future because of
they don't equip themselves they stop
equip themselves
and they dream about going back to the
normal work that
we used to do so those is the thing that
i
see thank you thank you for sharing
um and i have to say that during the the
its
program we also had to adapt to
changing um situations right and at some
point like it seemed that
everyone was going back to teaching in
person and then like we're saying like
great we will support you to think about
like how is it
to come back to the classroom and then
it's like change of plans
everything is going to back to virtual
and everyone is um
uh all of our our scholars were really
scrambling to
kind of like adapt to those new plans so
um
we came up with the concept of
ambidextrous
educators right those who are equally
uh comfortable and um and capable
of teaching in person or virtually right
it's just a matter of thinking about
what are the design constraints and i'm
going to design an experience for that
right and so i think that they benefited
from
participating in the program because we
kind of like said let's
explore how do we translate you know
from one to the
one medium to to the other um sherry i
wonder
like you as an educator and someone who
you know uh is very involved in
in your department and and what happens
at stanford what are some of the
surprises or some of the the interesting
things
um in which you have seen education
change and maybe like
some changes that may be here to stay
so you know i think i think everyone in
the world
world has professionally had to to have
this agility and i love learning this
new
phrase leticia the ambidextrous educator
you know i see among my colleagues some
excitement of actually
retaining some of the technology that
has really
had us think in different ways about the
relationships we have with our students
and you know one example is a colleague
now who has
more office hours using discord you know
a
technology that was actually created for
the gaming world
and it you know allows him to have an
open window
while he's doing other work in the
evening to have students who are working
on a project
say hey professor carrier we have we
have a question for you
and so you know that's a piece of it
that he's going to retain
um we've also experimented with kits
and mailing out kits to students and you
know how does
that allow them in different ways to
explore the physical concepts
right at their own desk instead of going
in
always to a laboratory you know i think
we're still struggling though
with relationships and i'll say the body
language that happens when you're in a
physical space with someone else
and you're having a conversation and you
know you lose some of those subtleties
so we're working on you know where do we
still need and want
that physical engagement um i would say
a lot more of my colleagues have
experimented with what's called the
flipped classroom
so that the the lecture part really
becomes
a fairly well produced um period you
know
of you plug it in and you play it and
you hear the professor go through the
concepts
and demonstrate some of it with a
whiteboard
but then you use the classroom time to
really engage
with a wicked problem you know where
students would work on teams
and be taking those concepts and really
using them as
tools to advance their thinking about
that wicked problem
so many more people have experimented
with that
than would have you know if had there
not been um
the pandemic and i would say a fair
number of them are going to retain that
idea
of flipping the classroom and really
thinking much more intentionally about
when can technology provide a different
portal into office hours
and when do we still need people sitting
around a table
arguing kind of face to face or
listening to one another
face to face so i think we have a lot
more i would say
lovers leticia to be thinking about in
terms of
what are we trying to achieve as
educators what are our objectives
and what are the designs that are going
to allow us to get there
thank you thank you for sharing that um
i have a question
um and i'll rephrase a little bit um
from junior sherman about uh the
well-being of employees and students
um so um we always like to view
uh the the whole student right like not
just the grades but also their
activities passions
uh aspirations um how are you supporting
the well-being of employees
as they transition or young employees
as they transition from the university
to the workforce right like an
and what might be like potentially a
um like i wouldn't say a shock but it's
like a
change in expectations in
roles etc how do you address that
i think this is very difficult questions
um but
what they have to say is that um when
they graduate from
from from the school they are kind of
the
kind they are the senior of the school
when they come to the workplace
they have the they are the junior they
are the youngest
in the in the organizations they have to
they have to shift
their mindses um quickly and they have
to learn
quickly to really adapt into the culture
of the of the of the company
and um the way that the corporate will
help them is that
we understand that most of the younger
generations they are open
to really learning new things so we have
to give them opportunity
to really learn and really um
execute things that they can do good so
that to build them
their confidence in the organizations
that they can do things they have to
open for their ideas
and then let them do the
things by themselves this is the way
that we
try to manage the new and younger
generations
in our company
thank you for ais i think that the
the benefit of the internship is very
helpful
when we select the student who come for
the internship
that that's the other gate of the
recruiting for the new graduate
because they they spend some time you
know
without the the worrying about the
performance evaluation because they are
students
so so we we include number of the
students who
were doing the internship with us that's
one thing
second thing is we use the the platform
and
also the ias academy to follow up in
terms of the first three months
on the you know on the coaching on all
the mentoring
for the new staff as the journey of the
orientation
last but not least is the body and the
course
from their hiring managers that need to
be assigned
because it's one help them not feeling
lonely
and we see the power of
the the new graduate
when they come together the power of
them to get together we call the project
is called the bloom we recruit the new
graduate
in the same time they put them together
we put them together and learning about
number of uh
soft skills or the readiness program
for a certain period of time and then
they start building their connection
after that they they go to their
hiring department but we see the
connection amongst them
it's also helped them to adapt to the
change that require in an organization
so those
those the sample from ais
thank you so much for sharing and and
we're at time i'd like to
um thank all of the
participants in the panel for your
thoughtful questions
um it's really exciting as we shared
before
that the its program will continue for
one more year and we will put in the
chat
a link to a form that if you personally
you're an educator and you're interested
or
you know an educator a university
educator who might be interested in
participating in the next cohort
you can enter your email there and we
will communicate
all of the details once those
have been uh defined um and uh
finally i'd like to personally thank uh
our panelists uh
concatenate concreting
uh who was with us earlier um
and not only uh for your support your
general support to make
the its program uh possible but for in
your intellectual partnership um and
your
um you know uh willingness to have these
conversations with educators and to
think together
how can we have you know industry and uh
academia collaborate uh and you're in
emotional
in in uh investment um in
um in getting uh to a better
education system in thailand and uh
beyond so thank you so much and i'm
going to
pass uh devaton to my colleague
matt to close the panel
thank you so much leticia and once again
thanks to all of you for joining us for
today's presentation and again i want to
echo leticia's comments my sincere
thanks to kun kantima
kunming kun kratin and kun nutsura
and of course my stanford colleagues
cherry and leticia for their wonderful
conversation and and i think both
inspiring and challenging sort of
thinking through the opportunities that
lay before all of us as educators and
people who work in education
institutions to think about how we can
transform
as mentioned earlier you can learn more
about the upcoming its program
opportunities and that link that was
just shared again
by clicking on that that was shared in
the chat and of course we'll be making
this talk available
uh on our websites but we'll be sharing
in social media as well so you can be
able to see it with
high subtitles uh subtitling as well uh
in the very near
future so thank you to all of you uh and
so uh